Hello again movie fans.
It's time for another challenging quiz to
test your cinematic knowledge with.
Do you think you know everything there is
to know about the weird and wonderful world
of movies?
Then get your teeth sunk in to this!
Coming up are ten questions about some of
the biggest movies around - both old and new
- and if you can get all of them right, then
you can truly consider yourself to be a serious
movie buff!
Keep your score as you go along and then leave
it in the comment section below!
Make sure you tell the truth though, because
you will be punished if we find out you're
lying!This is the latest edition of Screen
Rant's Ultimate Movie Quiz.
The Goonies
The Goonies looked like it was so much fun
to film.
The cast had an on-screen chemistry that was
second-to-none, so it's hard to believe that
any of the cast members didn't get along in
real life - but two of them really didn't.
Which two was it?
A - Anne Ramsey and John Matuszak
B - Josh Brolin and Kerri Green
C - Corey Feldman and Martha Plimpton
(Screen lights up C)According to Corey Feldman's
autobiography "Corerography", he and Martha
Plimpton - Mouth and Stef, respectively - didn't
get along at all.
This notion has been confirmed by Plimpton
herself, who has gone as far as describing
Feldman as a "fucking asshole".
Gremlins
At the start of Steven Spielberg's Gremlins,
the cinema in the town in which the movie
is set is showing movies called "A Boy's Life"
and "Watch The Skies", but which movies that
Spielberg had previously worked on were these
actually the working titles of?
A - E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial and Close Encounters
of the Third Kind
B - Amblin' and Firelight
C - Raiders of the Lost Ark and Poltergeist
The names of the two movies being shown in
the fictional town of Kingston Falls were
actually the working titles of E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial
and Close Encounters of the Third Kind, respectively.
Home Alone
Contrary to the nature of many of his roles
as an actor, Joe Pesci is actually a really
nice guy.
So what did he do while filming Home Alone
to help Macauley Culkin think he was mean,
so that Culkin would deliver a convincing
performance opposite his character Harry Lyme,
the burglar?
A - He had him visit the set of Goodfellas
to watch him film a scene as a gangster
B - He completely avoided Culkin on set
C - He stole his lunch
In order to make Macauley Culkin think he
was mean, just like his character Harry, Joe
Pesci deliberately avoided the then-child
actor between takes on the set of Home Alone.
Cloverfield
2008's Cloverfield was a monster movie with
a difference, in the sense that it was filmed
in the "found footage" style, but images from
which three classic monster movies appear
within the film?
A - King Kong (1933), The Beast from 20,000
Fathoms (1953) and Them!
(1954)
B - Godzilla (1954), The Fly (1958) and Alien
(1979)
C - King Kong vs. Godzilla (1962), Tentacles
(1977) and Tremors (1990)
Images from King Kong, The Beast from 20,000
Fathoms and Them! are hidden within Cloverfield.
Each image is seen for just a single frame.
The "Them!" picture is shown at 00.24.06,
the "Beast from 20,000 Fathoms" picture is
shown at 00.45.27, and the "King Kong" picture
is shown at 1.06.55.
Batman: The Killing Joke
This year, DC's animated feature Batman: The
Killing Joke got a limited theatrical release
and a home video release, but it initially
went into production in 2009.
What prompted its initial cancellation?
A - Mark Hamill's refusal to reprise his role
as The Joker
B - The 2008 death of Heath Ledger
C - The underperformance of Watchmen at the
box office
When Watchmen - another R-rated DC Comics
movie - underperformed at the box office in
2009, the planned production of Batman: The
Killing Joke in the same year was cancelled
due to fears of a similar commercial reaction.
Captain America: Civil War
In the epic comic book movie Captain America:
Civil War, there's a scene in which Ant-Man
is fired on an arrow by Hawkeye.
This is taken directly from the comic books,
but which comic book was it from specifically?
A - Tales of Suspense #57
B - The Avengers #223
C - Civil War: Front Line #1
It was actually an Avengers comic book - The
Avengers #223 - from which that Ant-Man-on-an-arrow
scene was taken.
The comic in question is from 1963 and has
that scene as its front cover.
Blair Witch
2016 will finally see the release of a sequel
to 1999's The Blair Witch Project that is
worthy of the name (we try to forget about
2000's Book of Shadows).
It will be called "Blair Witch", but what
was the movie's working title?
A - The Chase
B - The Witch
C - The Woods
Blair Witch was originally promoted under
the faux-title The Woods and was finally revealed
as being the third movie in the Blair Witch
franchise at the 2016 San Diego Comic Con.
Miss Peregrine's Home for Peculiar Children
When it comes to the aesthetics of his movies,
Tim Burton likes consistency.
Miss Peregrine's Home for Peculiar Children
will see him collaborating with costume designer
Colleen Atwood on a movie yet again, therefore.
How many times have they worked together in
this way in the past?
A - 8
B – 10
C - 12
Miss Peregrine's Home for Peculiar Children
marks the eleventh collaboration between costume
designer Colleen Atwood and Tim Burton, meaning
the pair have worked together on ten occasions
previously.
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs
1937's Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs is
still the highest-grossing animated movie
of all time when adjusted for inflation.
It was also the highest-grossing film ever
for exactly one year, after which it was knocked
out of the top spot by which movie?
A - Gone With the Wind
B - Goodbye, Mr. Chips
C - The Wizard of Oz
Having held the title of highest-grossing
film ever for exactly one year, Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs was knocked off the top
spot by Gone with the Wind - which remains
the highest-grossing film ever when adjusted
for inflation today.
World War Z
The movie adaptation of Max Brooks' brilliant
World War Z featured Doctor Who star Peter
Capaldi as an actual doctor, and he was listed
in the credits as having a very relevant name.
What was that name?
A - W.H.O.
Doctor
B - Doctor Tardis
C - Doctor T. Lord
Capaldi's character was credited using the
name W.H.O.
Doctor.
W.H.O. stands for World Health Organisation,
which was the organisation his character worked
for.
The film makers had inside knowledge that
Capaldi would soon be portraying the title
role in Doctor Who and his casting was announced
two months after World War Z was released.
Thanks for watching and for taking part in
our latest behind the scenes movie facts quiz.
Did you enjoy this video?
How well did you do with the questions?
Leave your score in the comment section below
and don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos like this one!